so we're now on the fifth or sixth day
whatever it is a fake media driven
controversy over Florida's history
curriculum on the subject of slavery
which the median Democrats claim
promotes and defends slavery itself
that's what the curriculum does
according to them this is all totally
made up and ridiculous of course and I
explain why in detail a few days ago you
can go and watch that segment if you
want just to summarize in a sentence or
two the curriculum teaches in great
depth about slavery slavery is mentioned
like 150 or 200 times in the curriculum
itself one of those mentions one just
one one sentence in the curriculum notes
that slaves after being freed sometimes
utilize skills that they learned while
Enslaved the point of including that
note in the curriculum is because for
one thing it's true
and we want to teach kids things that
are true and for another obviously it
was meant to be a tribute a credit to
the slaves themselves
obviously that's the intention
so just just to illustrate the point
I want to read you a quick passage from
the Wikipedia entry for a prominent
tailor and clothing designer designer
named Martin Greenfield
okay and he was never an African slave
but you'll understand why I'm reading a
second
during this time in Auschwitz Greenfield
learned the power behind clothing after
being beaten for accidentally ripping a
Nazi shirt he stole it repaired it and
wore it underneath his uniform all
throughout his time in the camp wearing
the shirt made him realize that clothes
possessed power this became an
inspiration of Martin helped him survive
the Holocaust this experience was a
contributing factor to how he became one
of the most successful and famous men's
tailors of America now
would anyone read that anecdote and
imagine that it's somehow a defense of
the Holocaust
okay is anyone is it would anyone
imagine that the argument being
presented here is that it's good that he
was in a concentration camp no obviously
it's a supposed to be a credit to
Greenfield that his success could be
traced back to a moment of uh such great
trial and tribulation if somebody wrote
a biography of this guy and mentioned
this fact
not only mentioned it but probably made
it like a central part of his life story
nobody in the world would interpret that
as some sort of attempt to minimize the
Holocaust and yet when it comes to
telling the exact same kind of story
about some slave Suddenly It's racist
as if everyone can't immediately
understand the point the whole reason
this was mentioned in the curriculum was
that it was supposed to be a way of
paying tribute to Slaves who were able
to convert tragedy into Triumph usually
we respect that kind of thing
that's obviously the point if you don't
understand that then you're either
incredibly stupid or pretending to be
stupid or else you've been duped by the
leftist media which makes you pretty
dumb as well so no matter what it's like
you're stupid or you're telling you
stupid those are really the only options
uh speaking of stupid
um here's Spike Lee reacting to this
whole controversy watch
is now saying that there's no agenda
here I don't think he's
he's educated about
enslavement of my ancestors I just want
to read the text again of what Florida
is now requiring for middle middle
school students it says instructions
should include quote how slaves develop
skills which in some instances could be
applied for their own personal benefit
how can it be through your personal
benefit when we was treated as enslaved
person it's not like
I'm a black spoke I'm gonna put a
shingle out there I'm gonna be a
blacksmith you you were owned one of the
arguments being made by supporters of
Governor DeSantis is that uh that
schools were teaching kids to hate
America by teaching uh you know the the
history of slavery in this country the
the history
um you say love America by learning the
truth
the good
indifferent and bad
that's what America is
this is the level I mean this is it
everything you just watched there that's
the level of discourse on the left
that's what you get from cable news now
that's it right there I mean everything
you heard it's just a combination of
straw men red herrings
total nonsense I mean I don't even know
where to start Spike Lee doesn't even
know what a blacksmith does begin with
first of all
okay blacksmiths they don't do Roofing
uh so I don't think he quite understands
that
and no one is saying that the slaves
benefited from these skills while they
were enslaved
that's not the point Spike
uh and then everything Anderson Cooper
said at the end is a total lie
oh the critics of this uh you know the
people defending the curriculum say that
if we teach about slavery kids will hate
America no one's saying that no one is
saying don't teach about slavery no one
has ever said that it's part of American
History I'm a big fan of teaching
American history teach the whole thing
it shouldn't be the sole focus and if
you're going to teach about slavery
teach the whole story of it
okay if kids graduate high school after
uh K through 12 13 years of formal
education and they think
that slavery was unique to America or
Western Civilization which many kids do
that's a failure of the education system
you haven't taught them the whole story
it's like a basic fact of human
civilization they don't know so yeah
absolutely teach about slavery teach
everything about it teach the whole damn
thing
and then teach the rest of American
History too so no one is saying that
but you notice something Spike Lee never
had a problem with this kind of
instruction
um with these facts about slavery being
taught until now none of these people
did as the daily wire reports quote the
College Board included a similar goal in
its course framework for AP
African-American studies for 2023
through 2024 the curriculum identifies
as Essential Knowledge this quote in
addition to agricultural work enslaved
people learn specialized trades and
worked as painters Carpenters tailors
musicians and healers in the North and
South once free African-Americans use
these skills to provide for themselves
and others the college boards AP college
prep classes are available in thousands
of schools across the U.S how is that
any difference from what you hear in the
in the curriculum in Florida it is not
different it's the exact same point
it's being taught in AP classes in
thousands of schools and not just this
year by the way
but for a long time no one ever had an
issue with it no one ever brought it up
until now
you know a company is uh looking out for
you when they actually upgrade your
service and don't charge you for it this
is great news for new and current uh
Pure Talk customers pure talk just added
data to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you've considered pure
talk before but haven't made the switch
well take a look again for just twenty
dollars a month you'll get unlimited
talk text and now 50 more 5G data plus
their new mobile hotspot you get all of
that this is why I love Pure Talk
they're veteran owned and they only hire
the best customer service team located
right here in the great USA most
families are saving almost a thousand
dollars a year while enjoying the most
Dependable 5G Network in America
remember you vote with how you spend
your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you when you go to puretalk.com Walsh
you'll save an additional 50 off your
first month because they actually value
you that's puretalk.com Walsh puretalk
Wireless for Americans buy Americans you
know buying a new car can be a stressful
experience for anyone especially if
you're a first-time buyer if you have no
credit before you walk into a dealership
and spend the entire day with the crowds
stress or potential not even find the
right car you need to check out car Zing
carzing is completely changing the way
you buy a car online by partnering with
Credit Agencies lenders and over 25 000
dealers Nationwide karzing provides you
with everything you need before stepping
foot into a dealership once you find the
right car your ideal budget you'll have
uh everything you need to get a deal
voucher and go into the dealership and
finalize your next ride it is very
simple even if you're not in the market
for a new car you should check out cars
anyway karzing's online window shopping
experience goes beyond near images you
can dive deep into each vehicle's
specifications features performance
capabilities zoom in on the
craftsmanship of the Interior Marvel The
Cutting Edge technology and admire the
meticulous attention to detail that sets
these automobiles apart from the rest
carsing also helps make your experience
faster cheaper less stressful visit
carzing.com walls today and find the
best deals near you that's carzing.com
Walsh but you know it's one thing to
have the left jumping on this bandwagon
the problem is when the right joins in
the race-baiting dog pile which the
right has shown increasingly increasing
willingness to do
first representative Byron Donalds who's
a Republican representative tweeted his
General support for the curriculum but
said quote the attempt to feature the
personal benefits of slavery is wrong it
needs to be adjusted
and then Tim Scott jumped in yesterday
with this listen
as the country founded upon Freedom
greatest deprivation of freedom for
slavery
there's there's no Silver Lining and
freedom in slavery the truth is that
anything you can learn that any benefits
that people suggest if you had during
slavery you would have had a free person
uh well slavery was was really about
separating families
about mutilating humans and even raping
their wives it was just devastating so I
would hope that every person
in our country and certainly running for
president would appreciate that and
listen people have bad days sometimes
they regret what they say and we should
uh ask them again to clarify their
positions
okay you you are being manipulated Tim
by the left
into explaining why slavery is bad as if
anyone doesn't understand that
and also accusing your own side of not
of of what being pro-slavery or thinking
that there are good things
this is this is all from the left and
you Tim Scott when you I just read you
the uh the standards for AP college
courses why don't you ever say anything
about that you never cared about that it
was never a problem it wasn't a problem
until the left in the media told you and
kamila Harris told you that it's a
problem and now it's a problem for you
uh you know one thing I've heard from
some people on the right who have said
you know it is a little look I don't
know I don't like that language in there
are you pathetic morons
why is it a focus you know we don't need
to fight it's not the focus you idiots
who's not the focus it's one thing
mentioned out of 190 things
the left made it a focus and you are
stupid and going along with it
because you haven't learned how these
people operate
and to start with any time you hear the
left saying anything about anything
related to race
never believe it on face value assume
that they are lying because they always
are
if you are saying something about a race
related issue or a gender related issue
or any issue related to any so-called
protected class if you're saying
something and it's exactly the same
thing as what Kamala Harris is saying
you need to stop and think very hard
about that
because the chances that she's being
that she's right and being honest are
infinitesimal
now I know that I'm saying all this and
you know the Tim Scott was being
manipulated I mean I'm myself I'm being
somewhat naive because he's running for
president and uh and he probably knows
exactly what he's doing
um
but he's attacking from the left and if
there is one commandment if there is one
rule that we should all follow
okay it's not it's not you know never
attack your own side never criticize
your own side no that's not the rule of
course you criticize your own side I'm
criticizing Tim Scott right now not that
he's really on my side
but you never attack from the left ever
ever you never go after your own side
from the left go after them you
criticize them
never from the left that is the
unforgivable sin
if there's one sin among conservatives
it is attacking your own side from the
left you do that and you are
you you you are you should be dead to us
at that point the moment you did do that
it's over
you adopt the less talking points to go
after your own side screw you you're
done we don't need you
go join them if you want to play this
game if you want to play the game of
pretending
that that there are like conservatives
who need you to explain to them that
slavery is bad if you want to play that
game then just go away go play it with
the left go become a Democrat that's
what you are
I have no patience for this it's
absolutely disgraceful and I hate it
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts